this is a pet peeve of mine we're not
allowed to say that our side won the
Cold War it just ended well let me point
out one thing the United States is still
here in the Soviet Union went defunct we
want
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special we are
pleased to welcome today Peter Robinson
he is the Murdock distinguished policy
fellow at the Hoover Institute and he
knows like everything about Reagan and
history and America
well Peter thank so much for stopping by
Ben it's a pleasure it's a pleasure I'm
an admirer but I have three sons who are
Ben Shapiro fanatics so it's it's a
double pleasure well thank you it's a
pleasure to have you on and I'm glad
that your sons will finally watch
something that you produce right so
let's start with via for folks who don't
know your resume you're sort of most
famous resume points that you wrote down
the tear down this wall speech that's
right at the at the Berlin Wall for
President Reagan so how exactly did you
come up with that phraseology how did
that speech come about oh well there's a
there's there's a story there 1987
spring of 1987 Berlin is celebrating
some a 800th anniversary Gorbachev is
going to visit the Queen of England is
going to visit and the West German
government remember was West German in
East Germany in those days the West
German government asked President Reagan
to make a visit I got assigned this
speech and flew to Berlin before of this
would be six weeks or so before the
president was to speak there to do some
research I went to the wall and went to
the place where the president was going
to be delivering the speech it's all
gone now but the wall was there the
Reichstag which was still parked with
shell case shell marks from the bombing
this at the final battle of Berlin and
behind it may was West Berlin modern
city color life movement recent model
cars and then you look over the wall and
there was almost no motion guards
marching back and forth it was as though
the color had been leached out of it
everything was grey brown the buildings
even looked dilapidated so there was it
this was a place where you could feel
the weight of of history
communism their capitalism here this was
the place where the Soviet advance
stopped at the end of the Second World
War this was the place where the
Americans and the the British had had
taken over so at that moment I was a
young speechwriter in trouble because
what could I write that would equal what
you felt there the felt weight of
history
several other stops in Brooklyn
including one to the ranking American
diplomat who is full of ideas about what
Ronald Reagan should not say West Berlin
is surrounded by East Germany the people
who live here are very sensitive to the
nuance and subtlety involved necessary
for east-west relations don't have
Ronald Reagan sound like an eddy
communist cowboy and by the way don't
heaven make a big deal about the wall
they've all gotten used to it
and that evening I went to a dinner
party but West Berliners whom I had not
met but we had mutual friends back in
Washington and so they put together a
sort of a buffet for me I fifteen or so
people different walks of life a
professor a couple of students and my
host and hostess were lovely retired
people he had worked at the World Bank
in Washington and retired back to West
Berlin and I asked the question I said
I've been told by the American diplomat
that you've all gotten used to the wall
by now and there was a silence and I
thought I've made just the gaffe that
the diplomat doesn't want Ronald Reagan
to make but then one man raised his arm
and pointed and said my sister lives
just a few kilometers in that direction
but I haven't seen her in more than 20
years how do you think we feel about
that wall and they went around the room
they stopped talking about it they had
not stopped caring about it they had not
stopped hating it and each person told
our one man talked about walking to work
each morning and each morning he would
walk under a guard tower where there was
an East German soldier with a rifle over
his shoulder who would peered down at
him with binoculars and the man said we
share the same history we speak the same
language but one of us is a zoo keeper
and the other is an animal and I have
never been able to decide which was
which and then our hostess a lovely
woman called ingerborg else who just
died a couple of years ago she must have
been younger than than I am now she was
in her perhaps in her early 50s she was
a very gracious woman she'd been
charming throughout the dinner party but
now she became angry and she said if
this man Gorbachev smacked her made a
ball of one fist inspected into the palm
of very of her other hand if this man
Gorbachev is serious with this glass
knows this perestroika he can
prove it by coming here and getting rid
of that wall and that went into my
notebook because the moment she said
that I knew that if Ronald Reagan had
been there in my place he would have
responded to that remark the simplicity
the dignity and the power of that remark
so the answer that's a long way around
to get to the answer to your question
but the if the question is where did
that phrase come from the answer is it
started with a German woman who lived
behind the wall herself so obviously
you're the author of some of the most
memorable words in American history to
emerge from the mouth of a President of
the United States and there's been this
kind of take on president manage or do
real that question right away the press
this is this is a slightly complicated
point to make but it but it's used it's
important to make I'm not the author I
wrote it but all I was trying to do when
I was in Berlin was listen as Ronald
Reagan would have listened respond as
Ronald Reagan would have responded and
write a speech for him now so I had
worked for Vice President George HW Bush
a man whom I I liked very much whom in
all kinds of ways I revere I would never
have written that speech for him nor
would he ever have given it we could
come to this if you'd like to but there
was a big fight over the speech the
National Security Council the State
Department tried to squelch that line
tear down this wall and Ronald Reagan
alone insisted on delivering that speech
as as I had written it so it is true
that as a speechwriter in the White
House I put the words on the paper but
the deeper truth is the author of that
speech the man who called it into being
and the man who insisted on it and the
man who delivered it in a way that
remains
I think permanently fixed in hundreds of
thousands of memories is Ronald Reagan
so speaking of that sort of rhetoric one
of the things that's happened in modern
American politics is is this debate now
over the value of presidential rhetoric
so you saw it a lot from the pro
rhetoric side when Barack Obama was
president the President Obama was very
mellifluous that he spoke with great
beauty and he was a great order and
never rated in my opinion well I want to
I want to get your take on that right
but the
was that if he had policy shortcomings
they were fulfilled by the fact that he
was this this wonderfully great orator
with with a gift and then you have
President Trump and most of his
defenders will say okay well don't pay
an attention to anything that he says
it's what he does that matters it's not
as rhetoric that matters it's the stuff
that he does because you know there's
teleprompter trumpet then there's non
teleprompter Trump so how seriously
should we take a president's rhetoric
what percentage of the job of the
presidency do you think is related to
rhetoric and how much is related to
policy when you've got it right and I
would argue that Ronald Reagan had it
right almost all the time when you've
got it right there's no distance between
the president and the rhetoric so that's
why as you just heard me say I had
Ronald Reagan in my mind by the time
Reagan became president
don't forget he'd been speaking in
public since at least the 1940s he'd
campaigned for Harry Truman for
president in 1948 as part of liberal uh
what was it Hollywood for Truman and and
Reagan now his views changed by 1964 he
endorses Barry Goldwater's run by 1964
Reagan as a conservative but Ronald
Reagan is speaking in public writing his
own speeches he comes to the White House
fully formed as a speaker also by then
he's thoroughly conservative he's fully
formed in his policy viewpoints and the
reason the reason there was a fight over
the Berlin Wall speech the reason there
were fights over quite a few of
President Reagan's speeches is that the
entire administration understood that
giving speeches was perhaps more than
any other the central instrument of
governance to Ronald Reagan he talked to
the American people there's inst one
instance after now I can remember 1986
tax reform we don't have the votes in
the Senate and the president goes one of
the problems is a Senate Republican
senator called Robert Caston bomb from
Wisconsin and the president goes
President Reagan goes and spends a day
in Wisconsin I remember that because I
wrote the speech he gave in Aashna he
speaks in Milwaukee and I wrote the
speech he gave in Oshkosh and there's a
day of press before he gets there the
local press for the president
then he gives the speeches and three or
four days later Robert Caston changed
his mind and decided to support the 1986
tax reform so Regan is working the
landscape of the American people he's
and and he's using speeches to enunciate
policy and to move opinion outside the
Beltway he is he is he is president by
addressing the American people and
letting the Beltway fall into line fall
into place afterwards okay Barack Obama
I took a shot at Barack Obama's rhetoric
when he was speaking to a large crowd
and he was in the mode of the African
American church he he was capable of
speaking beautifully and movingly but
that's only one mode and there were a
lot of speeches that he gave Rose Garden
speeches straightforward addresses that
were pretty clunky and really not all
that was surprisingly badly written in
my humble opinion and you sort of wonder
you think is this Barack Obama is that
one of the twenty really smart people he
has working around him okay and then we
come to Donald Trump Donald Trump as I'm
shiet am i sure you'll agree well I'll
see what you see I'll see what you say
to this Donald Trump has given at least
half a dozen really good speeches he's
the speech he delivered in Saudi Arabia
was an impressive thing his State of the
Union address the first speech he gave
to a joint session after becoming
president was beautifully written and
pretty darned well delivered he have a
very impressive speech in Vietnam in my
judgment the finest speech he delivered
was in Warsaw right where he said do you
remember this speech okay so he said
defense Western civilization though
exactly the question of our time is
whether whether Western civilization can
defend itself you can build an entire
administration around that you can build
a four-year and indeed an eight-year
agenda in foreign policy and domestic
policy on the defense of the values of
the west and he gave the speech and then
tweeted something else and tweeted
something else and tweeted something
else and so the press doesn't take those
big speeches seriously when they're with
by Donald Trump and in some way neither
does
anybody else because everybody knows
that wasn't really him that was some
very gifted speech writers that's not
ideal so again I repeat the point
there's a little trap here I so revered
Ronald Reagan and he to me he got so
many things right but I don't want to
let this very clever young man who
graduated from Harvard Law School
maneuver me into sounding like a
dinosaur nevertheless young man
nevertheless my boy study up on Ronald
Reagan that's that's where you get it
right where there's no distance Reagan
worked very care so this is another
point about Ronald Reagan he went over
he took the speeches seriously you'd
finish a speech and go to the chief
speechwriter there'd be editing back and
forth and so forth and we owed our
drafts to the president typically 48
hours before he delivered them and he
would take the speeches with him to the
residents in the evening and they'd come
back the next morning marked up by
Ronald Reagan he read every line of
every speech and edited those things I
can recall one time coming into the
office it but for some reason the stays
in my mind it was a six page speech and
no changes in the first page no changes
and I felt Oh for once
he just decided to watch TV and forget
to learn speech and then on the last
page on the second-to-last line he had
changed one word and in some ways that
was almost more effective than anything
else you might have done because you
remember the president is reading every
word we write and if it's not just right
he'll change it so by the time he
delivered a speech it was really and
truly he had in some way internalized a
you get no feeling of a distance between
Reagan and his text so I want to ask you
about the do some myth-busting with
regard to the Reagan administration
because now were 40 years past the
initiation of the Reagan administration
and people have excuse bill to rub my
back but people people have built up the
this sort of weird myth in the aftermath
of Ronald Reagan that invariably cuts to
the detriment of today's Republicans yes
it's at a go to take a quick example
there
this weird idea that Ronald Reagan and
Democrats worked hand-in-glove that they
were best friends the Tip O'Neill and
Ronald Reagan were just like they worked
beautifully together as opposed to
democrats in george w bush or democrats
and donald trump and if only we were
back in the days of reagan with a
politician like reagan everything would
be all better how much of that is true
and how much of that is myth almost none
of it is true but there's a kernel of it
that is true now when I say almost none
of it is true the back and forth on
domestic policy but also in all kinds of
aspects of foreign policy Ronald Reagan
as you will recall wanted to give aid to
the Contras in Nicaragua and could not
get that through the House of
Representatives or when you're over the
iran-contra hearings Congress was
vicious on Ronald Reagan Tip O'Neill was
a tough seasoned Paul and he viewed it
as his job to take down Ronald Reagan
any way he could it was actually very
rough here are the differences in the
old days in Washington this is a little
commented on but I actually think it's
very important in the old days in
Washington members of Congress and
Senate lived in town
I remember Tip O'Neill showed up for
mass at the same Catholic Church that I
attended he was there on weekends he'd
show up he'd go up for communion he was
chat with people they knew each other
they played there coached Little
League's they got to know each other so
there's that takes some of the edge off
and then here this is a story which is
this is what people are getting at I
think and I believe this isn't actually
all that well-known Ronald Reagan
there's an assassination attempt as you
know and I heard this from somebody who
saw it happen it's late at night there's
no family around and Tip O'Neill shows
up and mrs. Reagan has left very strict
orders about who's permitted to get in
to see the president and who isn't and
the Secret Service really have no idea
what to do but he is the Speaker of the
House and then he goes and he drops to
his knees and prays that's inconceivable
today and of course by the time Reagan
recovers they're back at it again so
there's some there's some fundamental
respect they all for each other I'll
give you one other
as long as you've got me going on the
old you know I'm gonna pay a camera man
to put sugar in your gas tank before
this is over
bill Sapphire columnist for The New York
Times great man brilliant writer he was
a speechwriter for Richard Nixon and he
formed a club for all presidential
speech writers and what I started
attending the meetings of that club
there were people who had written for
Harry Truman who would show up and what
was striking about it was from the
Truman administration right through to
George HW Bush's administration it ended
with Clinton and it was really over by
the time the Obama speech writers
started coming but from Truman all the
way through to George HW Bush everybody
understood that their president and
their administration had in one way or
another been engaged in the same project
and that was the defense of the Republic
during the Cold War the Cold War was
serious and we have may have have had
our differences Carter to Ford and
Carter to Reagan and so but everybody
was engaged in the defense of the
Republic one overarching cause that
United every administration for four and
a half decades that was still going on
in the 1980s and again that tempered
that temper it prevented them from
becoming vicious with each other in one
fundamental sense everybody was on the
same side so this is actually what I
want to ask you about next don't ask you
about the post Cold War era and held the
end of the Cold War has shaped American
politics but first let's talk about all
the people who are out to get your data
we're talking about big tech companies
many of whom hate conservatives and are
seeking to use your data against you
we're talking about hackers who want
your data so they can take your money
and steal your identity why not protect
all of your online activity today I
really care about protecting my online
activity I'm online all the time which
means I'm vulnerable to hackers or I
would be if I weren't using Express VPN
I use Express VPN every time I go online
big tech companies can use your IP
address to match your Internet activity
to your identity or location when I use
Express VPN search engines and media
sites can't see my IP address
at all my identity is masked and
anonymous expressvpn has the added
benefit of encrypting 100% of your data
to keep you safe from people who you
don't want to have your information
expressvpn software takes just a minute
to set up on your computer or phone you
tap one button and you're not protected
so if you're like me and you believe
that your internet data belongs to you
and not giant tech companies or hackers
protect your online activity today with
expressvpn comm slash pen and you get an
exclusive offer for my fans that's
expressvpn comm slash been for three
months free with a one-year package
again visit expressvpn comm slash Ben to
get started expressvpn comm slash Ben as
somebody who was five when the Berlin
Wall speech was was spoken yeah the the
impression that was left in the
aftermath of the fall of the Berlin Wall
the end of the communist regime in the
USSR is that it was the end of history
that now everybody was friends again I
mean even if you watched Terminator 2
you have characters saying to each other
why did the Russians have missiles
pointed at us we're friends now and
there's this great feeling that arises
in America that basically it's all over
and it seems as though we've sort of
turned our guns on each other as opposed
to the existential threat that used to
exist out there maybe that was
temporarily lifted for a brief moment in
time after September 11th but we're
certainly back at it to an excessive
degree right now do you think that
Americans have enough in common now to
actually hold each other to see each
other as non enemies in the absence of
an existential threat like the Soviet
Union I do I do believe so I also
believe we have to work at what we have
in common so I'm trying to say something
I'm trying to put this in a way that
gives it some sort of edge or some some
sort of interest because this is the
kind of thing that you say on the radio
every single day and god bless you for
saying it but I didn't come here just to
agree with you on the other hand I will
identity politics the politics of
dividing Americans that's not only wrong
it's if that approaches in my mind
that's it that comes close to a kind of
wickedness because why is it think about
this immigration is a problem we have to
address blah blah blah but all that is
true but why is it that
a Mexican who just crosses that border
within a few months finds himself or in
a position to better the lot of his not
just his family but his village back in
Mexico what is it about this country
that permits remittances back to Mexico
of almost 30 billion dollars a year why
is it that one of the first things that
Chinese do Chinese the Chinese who since
1979 when Deng Xiaoping had his opening
to markets and now there are lots of
people in China who are rich what do
they do they try to buy real estate
right here in in Southern California
they try to invest their money in this
country what what what is going and the
answer of course is that the United
States of America is a miracle and it
needs to be cherished and sustained and
nurtured in every way we can people who
come here I'm trying to think back now
Ronald Reagan didn't live to see the
kind of uncontrolled immigration that we
have witnessed since he left office and
so he was fundamentally pretty relaxed
about immigration but what he always
understood what people of that
generation always understood was that
people come here to become American so
the idea that it is in the interest of
certain politicians you and I am sure
could go off and do a whole show on the
problems with California this
spectacular state so blessed in so many
ways so beautiful so filled with
enterprising and talented people and the
homeless and yes okay the problem with
California is the government of
California in who's interested now is to
colonize certain groups or communities
of people when they come here for
political purposes and try to trap them
in a certain kind of mindset instead of
permitting them to enter into the
fullness of American life that's just
wrong it is just wrong so the answer is
yes I do believe we have enough in
common we have our ideals we have
American history the resources of
American history from the Revolutionary
War
where
you see it seems providential the way
Washington is able to escape from
Brooklyn across to Manhattan the wind
blows it the right way at just the right
time the courage to stand up to what was
then the greatest empire on earth the
Civil War Lincoln this martyr in it
giving his life to hold the Union
together and to abolish slavery the
greatest generation in the Second World
War I would argue that the Cold War
which is a bipartisan project it begins
with Harry Truman it ends with ront with
George HW Bush and in-between
intellectuals behave by and large pretty
badly really during the Cold War but
it's ordinary American people who
continue to vote to sustain the
politicians who want to spend the money
to do what we need to do that that this
country is able to sustain that kind of
a project across four and a half years
four and a half decades rather until
communism collapses and the Soviet by
the way this is this pet peeve of mine
it is now we're not allowed to say that
our side won the Cold War it just ended
nobody won
nobody lost it just ended well let me
point out one thing the United States is
still here in the Soviet Union what
defunct we won so the resources of
American history the ideals that we have
the ability the this is with your book
on Western the right side of history
the astonishing thing about the Western
civilization is not that it's Western
it's that it it consists of permanent
truths which are open to anyone from
anywhere and the greatest exemplars of
that tradition in the world today is the
United States yes of course we have
enough resources if we choose to sustain
them well that is the next question is
do you think that we are going to choose
to sustain them so what I've seen is
that the left-right divide in the United
States right now seems to be breaking
down into two views of American history
one is the American history that you
just described that America was based on
fundamentally true eternally good
principles that we have strayed from
that we have tried to perfect our
performance of and that America is a
story of us trying to and striving to
live up to the
the Declaration the Constitution and
then there's the ultra to correct one I
mean great let's here okay and then
there's the alternative story which is
the story that the New York Times which
is to pay which is that all institutions
in America were rooted in slavery that
all of the all of the American history
was rooted in sexism and homophobia and
bigotry and that all of the grand ideals
of the Declaration of Independence were
basically just people making excuses for
their own bigotry to enshrine their own
economic power in the view of people
like Charles beard or to try and
enshrine their own superiority
ethnically in the view of perhaps time
and he see Coates so if you don't have a
common history it seems difficult to see
what exactly can sustain us because it
used to be that when you describe the
nation now group of people who we're
gonna live together we had at least have
a few things in common you have to have
a common language which is also being
discarded because we can't even decide
on what he and she mean anymore we used
to be able to have common religious
principles and we broaden that out to be
judeo-christian not just Christian and
now the United States has become
increasingly fragmented and and secular
in its in its religious pursuits we just
have a common history but that's been
Howard Zinn defied and so a huge
percentage of the population now
believes that American history is an
unalloyed record of bad punctuated by
beautiful moments of good which then
immediately received back into the muck
so do you think that we I mean the
resources are there do you think that we
are going to take advantage of those
resources I don't know one of the
straight so I am oment ago about the
resources of American history these
tremendously moving stories every one of
those was a close-run thing Marx was
wrong history is not predetermined it's
a question of we are human beings we
want one of the tenets of of what we you
and I both hold the judeo-christian
tradition is freewill we as individuals
have freewill we as a nation have
freewill we can certainly choose to let
it all go if we wish to do so and we can
by contrast choose to hold it all
together and cherish it if we do if we
wish to do that I honestly don't know I
cannot say I hope so I will fight for it
I congratulate you for fighting for it
it's actually I do congratulate you
there are easier ways for somebody who
graduated from Harvard Law School to
make money then than by waging war
against
that's a curve you didn't sound all that
great pagination bad but okay but let's
say that so so the answer is I don't
know that's that which isn't in some way
as a statement of the basic truth human
will we have free will history is not
predetermined I don't know well so so
for conservatives and for I say
conservatives not Republicans because I
really don't care about party
affiliation as much as I do about the
ideas that undergird some of that party
affiliation for conservatives this puts
them in sort of a weird spot because if
you're trying to reintroduce on
fundamental principle how do you think
the Trump administration plays into this
so I was obviously deeply uneasy about
Trump's election in 2016 I didn't vote
for either of the major candidates
specifically because I had significant
fears that President Trump was going to
toxify an entire generation of young
people to conservatism because he is
personally so divisive and polarizing
yeah I obviously underestimated how
conservative he would be in office I
thought he wasn't going to be
particularly conservative prior record
and then he turned out to be quite
conservative at least on everything
except for spending which no Republican
apparently is conservative in practice
on but the the question of how we unify
Americans around conservative principles
we're really just around basic American
history that question is very much open
from the right side of the aisle given
how polarizing Trump is so how exactly
should conservatives deal with Trump is
he an asset in this effort is he a
detriment to the effort or an obstacle
where do you think that so stands Donald
Trump will be gone in one year or five
and I have lived long enough this again
to tell you that even five years isn't
that long so conservatives should be
planning should be thinking should be
sorting out policy and planning on what
happens after Donald Trump's leaves as
for Donald Trump himself I quite often
get asked the question what would Ronald
Reagan have made of Donald Trump well of
course there are obvious points that the
bad language the indiscipline the
inability to seem to give a speech and
stick with the agenda laid out in the
speech Ronald Reagan would have found
all of that very distasteful on the
other hand Ronald Reagan was a practical
man
and a working politician the most
perceptive insightful political
scientist I've ever read was the old
vaudeville vaudeville comedian Henny
Youngman and here is the basis for all
truly useful political analysis
it's a Henny Youngman gag question how's
your wife answer compared to what all
right so the question about Donald Trump
is compared to what and compared to
Hillary Clinton Trump compared to Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren Trump Trump
this may be half crazy but I almost
think I want to when I consider Donald
Trump I almost I remember the way the
teachers used to tell us to look at a
solar eclipse when we were little kids
don't look at it you can look at the
shadow on the ground you can look at the
effects but you mustn't look at the
object itself so if you if you put your
hand over Donald Trump here's what you
see a growing economy growing more
robustly than it has in more than a
decade
you see unemployment rates at historic
lows among african-americans and
Hispanics the lowest unemployment rates
ever recorded what does that mean that
means that millions of Americans not the
press corps that can't stand Donald
Trump in Washington millions of ordinary
Americans and especially those toward
the bottom of the economic distribution
are leading better lives in this economy
people have come off welfare roles
they've come off food stamps they're
able to provide for themselves and their
families that's an achievement don't
look at that man but it's an achievement
all the same and so it goes with Donald
Trump the appointments the the
appointments to the federal bench that
the the never Trump or refrain so
Gorsuch yeah so Gorsuch and now so
Kavanaugh the C Constitution of the
United States has been saved for another
20 years we again don't look at him but
that's the effect of it foreign policy I
was disconcerted to see John John Bolton
leave the White House I think he's a
just as I was disconcerted to see Jim
mattis general mattis it's
down a Secretary of Defense or HR
McMaster as National Security Council
before John Bolton all that and yet at
the same time
Putin annexed Crimea under Obama he
moved into Ukraine proper again under
Obama under Trump he complains all the
time about NATO and yet we have troops
now part of a NATO exercise we have
troops in Poland right on the Russian
border is according to the Prime
Minister of Israel Israel Israel is
feeling as though it needs the United
States and is relying on the Trump
administration so we have it's you don't
want to say you have a three-year-old
son you don't want to say to your son
son one day I'd like you to grow up to
be just like Donald Trump that would be
a mistake I would talk you out of that
Ben but on the other hand him over what
the Democrats are trying to look as
though they're going to nominate yes
yeah so I fully agree with the analysis
in the in D versus measure I do wonder
about the the long-term view like let's
Telegraph this eight years down the line
or four years down the line or maybe two
years down the line depending on what
are these elections go I'm gonna ask you
to do that in just one second first
these days a lot of workplaces offer
employees some pretty nice perks like
for example we have food here at the
Daily wire we even have a place for our
employees to sleep if they so choose but
one of those perks at some companies is
life insurance but the truth is this you
don't want to rely on your workplace to
provide you a place to sleep like
producer Nick and you also don't want to
rely on your workplace life insurance
alone this is where policy genius comes
in policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in just a few
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price the
policy genius team can look at your
workplace life insurance policy help you
decide what else you might need and what
you actually don't and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home insurance which you need legally
when you buy a home and auto insurance
which you need legally to drive and
disability insurance
so remember workplace life insurance
policies they're like workplace snacks
or like that pup tent that we set up for
Nick they're better than nothing but
they are not quite enough head on over
to policy genius.com
today find out how to supplement your
workplace life insurance and better
protect your family policy genius it's
like a buffet but made of life insurance
and what
could be more delicious than that policy
genius.com go check them out right now
so let's talk about not the immediate
election because I agree with your
analysis which is if I'm made to choose
between Donald Trump and Elizabeth
Warren or Donald Trump and Joe Biden
that that's not a very difficult choice
I mean the fact is the Donald Trump on a
political level has given me most of the
things I want even well I have serious
reservations about his character and the
things that he says and as I think most
people do my concern is that somebody
who speaks to Millennials and people who
are younger than yes is that is that
Trump as a character that his the things
that he says actually have a long-term
impact on how people vote what we're
seeing from some of the polling data is
that people are not living by the the
supposed Churchill Maxim that that you
know you're liberal when you're 20 and
you're conservative when you're 40 that
that's not actually what's happening
that people are voting to the left and
then they're largely staying to the left
as they get older and this is increasing
with each generation that that
transition happened more with the
greatest generation that it happened
with the baby boomers a little bit less
and then it's happened with the
Millennials a lot less and then it's
happening with Gen Z who can't even vote
yet most of them but gen Z is going to
happen a lot is sort of the sort of the
prevailing sentiment so with that said
that puts conservatives in this bizarre
position because on the one hand you
want Trump to win in 2020 and that's a
lot a lot of people that I know and I
feel the pressure all the time that
never say a bad word about Trump because
if you say a bad word about it's all the
truth about him yes okay and it but the
idea is that anything you say about
Trump from one side is inherently
damaging to him and may lead to the
election of a Democrat something that I
don't actually agree with I think that
you can critique a politician and Trump
has proved himself to be strong enough
to take that he's taken enormous amounts
of abuse then there is the other side
which is the sort of Bill Kristol side
and I hesitate to mention names but it's
too little and and friends I mean I like
Bill Kristol too but but Bill's take
seems to be that anything that is good
for Trump is bad for conservatism
because Trump himself is bad for
conservatism so any small victory for
Trump is actually leading to the ascent
of a destructive force within
conservatism so even if you like the
judges if you say you like the judges
then you are actually giving effect to a
man who is carving the heart out of
conservatism future
I think is if I had to put a logic on
Bill I think that's probably what he's
trying to say what is the middle road in
that debate where should a how should
conservatives treat Trump well on the
voters if you want to scare me to death
I'll let you do it but here's what I'm
consoling myself with and again if you
want to scare me to death you just say
Peter yet again that's dated but here's
your here is also of some electoral data
the cohort that most strongly supported
Ronald Reagan was the youngest cohort
and that remained in effect for five six
seven years after he left office that
young people tended to be Republican
Reagan begins to draw people into the
Republican Party and there's a golden
moment it didn't last long it's only a
moment but there's a golden moment when
the Republican Party achieved parity
roughly achieved parity within a
percentage point or two with the
Democratic Party sometime around the
presidency as I recall of George HW Bush
then it all slid away the point I'm
trying to make is that political
preferences are actually pretty
malleable now if you want to say to me
that's changing and it's changing
against the Republican side you may be
right all I can say is that the Reagan
era wasn't all that long ago in
historical terms and as recently as then
political preferences were malleable
Donald it also seems to me here's where
Bill Kristol is right for sure there's
nobody like Donald Trump now that means
that when Donald Trump leaves the stage
whatever happens it's going to seem a
lot more normal than Donald Trump
so I just keep the argument there's some
merit to this I have good friends my
friend Andy Ferguson who's one of those
beautiful writers I know and one of the
finest people I know and he keeps saying
this is this is the Trump presidency is
corrosive of American character all I
can say is that seems to me
vague and uncertain and you'd have to
point out to me exactly how American
character
is being changed because here's what I
can point out to you growing economy
people leading better lives being able
to care for themselves and their
children that's what I the the Trump's
accomplishments they're the
accomplishments of the country you could
argue I think the correct conservative
way of putting it whenever we have
economic growth in this country it's
because the president got the government
out of out of the way you've really
achieved something when you've even
changed the mind of the other side and
now the tariffs the way he's going about
this trade war may be all wrong there
are a very well-versed economist who and
I know who say it's just wrong that
maybe but everybody understands that
we're up against something in China now
and even the Democrats would agree with
that Trump has put something on the
American agenda of first importance and
everybody has said across the political
spectrum yes he's right about that that
matters to the future of the country
these are these are tangible
achievements if you and I we could just
dim the lights for a moment and then
come back on and say to the America
we've just figured out who the next
president for sure you and I could come
up with somebody who'd give us the
policies and have a better more he'd be
easier to take let's move that way and
then Donald Trump we could do that would
take us 30 seconds that would take us
one commercial break that isn't the way
the system works so I just I I feel the
weight of the argument okay all the way
to the counter-argument to to target
against myself and that is that that is
assuming Trump versus a stagnant status
quo in the Democratic Party me know the
Democratic Party doesn't go completely
off the rails and we're watching right
now is a democratic party that is
embracing all of its own worst aspects
from the embrace of anti-semites like
ohan Omar to the embrace of radicals
like Bernie Sanders mean Bernie Sanders
was a kook for virtually all of his
political career and now Bernie Sanders
is the thought leader of the Democratic
Party and Elizabeth Warren who used to
be a fairly interesting think or at
least early in the 2000s has not only
embraced but it is doubling down on all
of Sanders ISM she said the other day
during that debate that's the the
climate debate that she would if I
understood this correctly she would
issue an executive order to eliminate
fracas okay first of all what happened
to the constitute that's
not something you can eliminate a quick
by executive Fiat you just can't do that
senator item1 item2 in the last what is
a decade or decade and a half and I'll
get the statistic a little bit wrong but
your viewers will be able to look it up
on Google and they'll see the point I'm
trying to make the United States has
reduced its greenhouse gas emissions by
as much as all of Europe combined Europe
which has a larger population and a
somewhat bigger economy and how have we
done that by using natural gas and how
have we driven down the prices of
natural gas to such a level that it's
displacing coal by fracking that crazed
person has said I'm going to eliminate
fracking which is precisely what has
enabled us to to lower greenhouse gas
emissions so you're quite right the
Democratic Party is not sad is I don't
know it's what is it like it's like it's
almost like watching that wonderful
movie One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
these candidates are getting crazier in
real time it is it is astonishing she
also said that you'd ban nuclear power
so basically the two best versions of
power on planet earth for reducing
carbon emissions are apparently out the
window and I suppose she'll be creating
wind farms with the wealth tax or
something it is astonishing to watch as
the Democratic Party moves in this
direction it's one of the reasons why I
think that you know to turn to the other
side their view of the future is
untenable I think that people are going
to get quickly very tired of the woke
scolding and the and the insane changing
lines of the left I mean you find
yourself literally on a day-to-day level
feeling like Indiana Jones in Last
Crusade trying to step letter to letter
to avoid dropping off into the middle of
nothingness because the lines are
shifting like every single day the lines
are shifting and you're seeing Democrats
themselves who are getting caught up in
these shifting lines and having to
apologize because the line shifted
yesterday and they they went to sleep
Joe Biden here's the way Joe Biden could
win in my opinion here's the way Joe
Biden could seize the nomination and
frankly sweep all the way to the White
House and defeat Donald Trump and here's
how Joe Biden could win Joe Biden could
say I grew up i Joe Biden grew up in
Scranton Pennsylvania in and to me the
Democratic Party when I think of the
Democratic Party
I think of Scranton where there were
coal miners those were the best jobs
that a lot of people could get and those
jobs mattered and the Democratic Party
is the party of jobs where there were
Irish like the Biden's and poles and
Slovaks and Italians and the Democratic
Party is the party of the immigrant
party but of immigrants who came to this
country to become Americans all of us
went to school together all of us
learned English all of us learned
American history that is the Democratic
Party that I stood for jobs ordinary
working people and also this was the
Democratic Party of people of faith the
Biden's went to Mass on Sunday and our
neighbors went to synagogue and the
Democratic Party should be a home for
the great American middle class and
working Americans who believe in the
traditions in which they were raised if
he said I'm done with you lunatics I
want to represent the Democratic Party
of Franklin Roosevelt and Bill Clinton
he would sweep to the White House in my
opinion now could Joe Biden try to move
the Democratic Party back to them back
to its own traditions the FDR party the
JFK party the Bill Clinton party III I
don't think that he has the stomach for
that frankly and and more importantly I
don't think the media are with him on
that I mean it is amazing how much of
this is all driven by the media which
does bring us to the question of the
media so Ronald Reagan obviously did
enormous battles with the media but it
seems as though it gets worse and worse
with each successive Republican
administration I mean something like 94%
of all press coverage of President Trump
has been negative he's obviously in
these knock-down drag-out battles with
the media in my opinion he he won the
election in 2016 by running against the
media as much as he won it by running
against Hillary Clinton it's pretty
obvious that right now his plan for 2020
is not even to run against the Democrat
it's to run against the media which is
why he's railing against the media so
much if I had to put my finger on one
area of American life that is increasing
the polarization and leading to the
radicalism and the and the ire of both
sides
would be the way that the media have
behaved over the past 20 years which has
completely stripped them of any patina
of objectivity and it used to be that
there at least was the patina now it's
been completely stripped it was a lie
before but now the lie has been unmasked
and not on mass by Republicans not on
mass by Trump unmasked by the media
themselves have decided to basically at
the same time come out of the closet as
overt Democrats and then still claim
that their objective journalist and
Gaslight the rest of America
mm-hmm I agree with every bit of that I
agree with absolutely every word of that
when I was being interviewed for my
position as a speechwriter David Gerken
then deputy what was he director of
communications in the Reagan White House
called I had me into his office in the
West Wing and he had in his office the
same television console you may not
recall this Ben but television could be
big pieces of furniture in the old days
that HR Haldeman had made had had made
for himself when he was chief of staff
to Richard Nixon and the television had
three screens one big screen and then
two smaller screens now why were there
three screens that was so that HR
Haldeman during Nixon and David Gergen
during Reagan could watch all three
nightly newscasts at the same time NBC
CBS ABC you read The Wall Street Journal
and The New York Times and The
Washington Post and you were done with
your morning reading done for the day
and then in the evening you watched half
our newscasts by CBS NBC and ABC and
then once again you were done now what
that meant was that all of those
entities had business incentives they
were for-profit businesses and they had
business incentives to reach to the
middle okay you know all about this that
model is just gone the media now is all
bits and pieces and fragments and what
our side can do is what you're doing we
simply have to found our own outlets as
yes mr. Murdoch Rupert Murdoch when he
founded Fox News well I have a business
insight here it's a if there's a niche
market that's underserved it's half of
the country
if this strikes me as non desperate
in the sense that our side is doing a
pretty good job between Fox News and The
Wall Street Journal and Ben Shapiro who
was either on ice mazing to me because
you're down the hall and I'm have you're
everywhere at once it apparently so all
that is good news we probably ought to
have more of it michael barone here's
the here's the last sort of consoling
point salving point that I make to
myself and I offer it to you michael
barone terrific journalist deep sense of
American history and Michael Barone
argues we've been here before that is to
say we've been we've had fragmented
press outlets that were highly partisan
and that was the way it was through much
of the 19th century so overwhelmingly
newspapers small every town had a
democratic newspaper or and a Whig
newspaper and a Republican newspaper and
they were vicious to each other and what
do you get during that period of
American history well of course you get
the Civil War that's unfortunate but
what fundamentally what you get is the
settling of the West and the emergence
of a great nation
it doesn't need to hold us back but we
cannot permit ourselves to be
condescended to and talked down to by
the people who run CNN and the New York
Times so I'm fortunate I get to talk
about ideas for living you get to talk
about ideas for a living and study them
and write about them but it does feel
that as attention spans whither and as
people are spending five seconds on each
story and as everything becomes Twitter
fied that the prospect of true
conversations have gone by the wayside
and I see this mostly in the area of
solutions so people spend an awful lot
of time online talking about problems
and then shouting at each other they
don't properly recognize the problem so
to take an example that just comes to
mind on the left they never talk about
actual practical solutions to climate
change it's all sloganeering about
getting rid of fossil fuels which is not
going to happen or coming up with some
vast global agreement with China and
India which is never going to happen and
then yelling at people that they are
climate deniers if they say that those
solutions are not actually going to work
and this seems to be working for a
certain number of Americans on the same
page you sort of see on the right side
of the aisle that objections on a
variety of issues
are more knee jerk than idea based at
least for the folks on Twitter that its
Twitter as I've put it as a place for
dunking and being dunked upon but it
seems that increasingly politics is a
place for dunking and being dunked upon
that solutions are secondary to problems
do you think that we are going to see a
reversion to debate over ideas or do you
think that this is sort of the new
normal and driven by social media so I
said at the top of this program I'm an
admirer of yours but I have three sons
who are just fanatics I have my oldest
son in particular Pedro
I'm just telling you this is I just
observe in my own family so he goes off
to a fancy school and his heroes people
he read about during college Jesus Moses
Maimonides no it's Jordan Peterson and
ben shapiro
and why is that of course because part
of it is because of your point of view
much of it is because of your point of
view but you two guys do Jordan Peterson
and you are doing plenty of long-form
you're both producing books
if this show is an hour-long show you're
not doing tweets this requires quite a
lot well actually I almost feel as
though at the end I should put on a red
tie and then ask my son if you saw me
wearing a tie just to see if you watch
watch all hour long of this episode but
so I don't know I know I have friends in
the publishing industry book sales are
up there is the podcasts podcast I do I
helped to found ricochet which is which
now you we've had you unlock of course
you oh you know okay so ricochet
everybody go to ricochet commerce yeah
okay great and it turns out that if you
do a half-hour podcast the comment is
could you make that an hour people want
people want to there there is a or I
think back to in the 50s and 60s and I
think it remains a strong through much
of the 70s you had the Book of the Month
Club do you remember reading about it if
it was gone by the time you appeared on
the scene but the Book of the Month Club
what it was what it was addressing was
this very American urge for
self-improvement to educate ourselves
that's what
democracy doesn't just mean you get to
vote it means means you get to be as
smart as anybody else and if you didn't
get a chance to go to a fancy school
there's still the Book of the Month Club
well of course The Book of the Month
Club is gone but I just see it over and
over now maybe it's because of the
Hoover Institution or I'm in something
like the business that you're in in the
sense that I do my own writing and we
have Ricochet and then I have uncommon
knowledge by own interview show and
people respond to this they're grateful
for it I just don't think I just don't
think that Twitter defines the American
character I just don't buy it I don't
see it I mean frankly I'm spending a lot
less time on Twitter just because I find
a soul-sucking and I think there there
are a lot of people who feel the same
way it's you can get the information
takes a little bit longer if you're not
on Twitter but at least you're not
spending all day jockeying for position
with people who hate your guts and that
saves you an enormous amount of time and
stress as it turns out so I want to ask
you about on the sort of your job
description isn't it yeah queue for
position with people who hate your guts
that yeah that's pretty much my slogan
actually right there under facts don't
care about your feelings we've put on a
t-shirt but I wanted to ask you about
uncommon knowledge you've had the
opportunity to interview an enormous
number of major public figures who did
you find the most interesting oh well
yeah in one way or another they're all
interesting of course but the the people
Christopher Hitchens Christopher and I
disagreed on almost everything
well actually Christopher there was
Christopher's kind of a layer cake on on
his literary criticism he read
everything in English literature and he
could he was his literary judgements
were always flawless in my opinion then
you get to politics and it's mixed
half-and-half and then you get to
religion and he was wrong every time he
opened his mouth but Christopher had
first of all he had a beautiful voice
and he was wonderfully articulate but he
had a integrity he was the kind of
sparring partner and you wanted because
he was in on Christopher Hitchens was an
honest man he would tell you
straightforwardly what his own
conclusions were and how he reached them
so there's Christopher Tom soul Tom soul
grew up in the south and to his until he
was a small boy
and then he was sent to live with
relatives in Harlem and he went and he
turned out to be a very intelligent very
bright boy who went to Howard University
in Washington Harvard University I
believe Columbia and the University of
Chicago I may have got but he holds
degrees for sure from Harvard and then
he has a masters and a doctorate in
economics and he started out as a
Marxist and fought his way through
fought his way through to the
conservative or I shouldn't say
conservative I'm not sure Tom would call
himself a conservative but certainly to
a free market libertarian position and
for an african-american to stand up to
the pressures that he's under is just
it's he's in he's funny and brilliant
and tough and resilient and ideas
matters so much that if he thinks the
conclusion is correct he will follow it
whatever the price I guess what I'm
saying is that there's a man who's been
willing to pay a price that's
tremendously impressive Milton Friedman
Milton Friedman whom I interviewed what
three or four times Milton Friedman has
been gone now he died deep in his 90s at
in 2006 if I recall correctly but he was
in many ways the most important
economist or certainly one of the two or
three most important economists of the
entire 20th century and we which I was
doing an interview with him this
actually this stays in my mind is one of
the one moment that I just went through
me and I asked a question and he
responded and I said well wait a minute
Milton you're not making an economic
argument you're making a moral argument
and he looked at me and said of course
I'm making a moral argument is there any
other kind of argument that matters oh
you get it
economics wasn't a game for him you you
you you worked your economic analysis
because it was human lives that were at
stake this was see
business fantastic fantastic this
brilliant man who was technically so
gifted technically at the top of his
field when it came down to it all the
arguments were immoral fantastic and so
I want to ask about the state of higher
education a little bit so you're
obviously at the Hoover Institution and
you've been around higher education for
for quite a while do you think that
higher education can be saved because it
seems as though it has fallen into
disrepair except for a few key sort of
institutions across the country that the
the gender studies theory of the of the
moment and the the attempt to pander to
the woke brigade has corrupted a lot of
the heart of higher education do you
think that that's a savable commodity
first of all let's draw a sharp
distinction between the stem stuff which
is doing just fine if you and I also I
do have the feeling some stem between
stem and humanities and I have a feeling
this is very disconcerting but I have
the feeling that in some places bright
kids are flocking to the sciences and
avoiding the humanities and where did we
see that happen before in the old Soviet
Union this is Sciences that were
uncorruptible then and that remain
incorruptible uncorruptible today so the
stem the sciences are doing just fine
the major American research universities
are without pure anywhere else in the
world as far as I can tell anywhere else
in history so that leads us to the
humanities and I don't know quite I'm so
I know way I'm too close to it because I
work at the Stanford University and then
I actually I was a trustee at Dartmouth
College my alma mater and my four oldest
children have all attended Dartmouth
College and so there's political
correctness everywhere and great
institutions can only hire the talent
that's coming up through the system and
the talent that comes up through the
system if you're in classics or English
or history it seems as though there's a
kind of political correctness and yet at
Stanford you have the kids who are
working on the Stanford review and many
of them are in the humanities and
Dartmouth you've got the
Dartmouth review that's where the
reviews were started you've got a
program at Dartmouth called the
political economy project which is a
place where specifically devoted
actually this is an interesting thing to
me this will take a moment or two to
more to explain when I went to college
in economics it was taught as a conflict
of great ideas political science or
government as we call it at Dartmouth
you began by studying political
philosophy you'd read John Locke you'd
read Aristotle the ideas have tended to
be squeezed out of the disciplines in
favor of quantitative techniques so what
you get in economics even introductory
economics these days you taught how to
run regression analyses you're not and
you can graduate four years at a very
fancy institution and have no clue what
all of this communism versus capitalism
stuff was about Milton Friedman versus
John Maynard Keynes Adam Smith versus
Karl Marx what was that all about
so that several professors at Dartmouth
have established a program for examining
the great ideas democracy versus other
forms of government capitalism versus
central planning so there are so many
there's a kind of bubbling up of a sort
of self-awareness that we may have lost
the thread here let's let it let's
establish a program here let's establish
a program there that I it's it's
impossible for me to my friend Peter
teal as much he just thinks I'm naive
and you may think I'm naive as well I
don't know but it's impossible for me to
to just wish wish the humanities out of
existence in American Universities I see
too many new shoots coming up growing up
so in one second I wanna ask you to
assess the health of the the Reagan
three-legged stool of politics because
we've seen all these debates inside the
conservative movement about our is that
still the model for the conservative
movement going forward if you want to
hear Peter Robinson's answer you have to
be a daily wire subscriber to subscribe
head on over to daily wire comm click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation over there well Peter thank
you so much for stopping by this has
really been a pleasure and really
appreciate I'm gonna smile
my pleasure
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Maynard post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Kamino hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20